all right it's been another week which
means another day of escapism let me say
that again escapism and an infected
zombie apocalypse our world is so I
can't swear in the first few seconds of
videos algorithm and all it's gonna give
you a fair spoiler warning I'm gonna
talk about things that happened in
episode six of The Last of Us this
episode jumps three months after Joel
and Ellie have licked their emotional
wounds after last week's tragedy well
last week to us three months to them but
that three month time Jump brings us to
what looks like winter and winter in the
game takes place after the events of
this episode as it relates to the game
anyway that's why I was like
wait a minute did we skip are we not
gonna have that Arc with Ellie that I
really like the arc I think it's a very
important chapter of her life but again
the show does a really good job at
keeping people who've played the game on
their toes to kind of shake it up a bit
to where you don't feel like you're just
watching the Motions play out long story
short they run across some folks on
horses they have this dog it's like all
right the dog is gonna sniff you out if
the dog senses anything if dog smells
anything that is any fungus dog is going
to find a new chew toy called you let
the games begin that was actually a
really intense scene because you're like
it's gonna Ellie's not technically like
her body fights it off but it's
huh you're scared Joel's scared you're
kind of more scared because he looks
scared like dude you're supposed to be
the rock what are you doing not the Rock
is in the actor but the concept you're
supposed to be the anchor you're
supposed to be the one we all get behind
you're our tank man don't look freaked
out turns out it's all good it's all
fine they go to the town and that's
where Joel's brother Tommy is they give
each other a big hug you know it's like
they have tension but I like that it
shows that it's like dude zombie
apocalypse you can have beef with your
brother you can also give him a really
big hug because you're glad he's alive
you thought he might have been dead at
this point they're a community of
Communists their words not mine Jill
seems very uncomfortable with the whole
thing I get it it's the same feeling I
got with like the Dharma Initiative and
I was watching Lost which is very easy
to say as I'm in my house behind my
camera talking about an episode of
Television I'm sure the chips were
actually down I'd feel like yeah you
want me to shovel [__] all day long
great thank you for the food in the
shelter things are very easy to say
until you're there but I totally get
Joel's apprehension I get one why he
doesn't feel comfortable in this setting
because he's he's made it on his own out
there for so long it's like I don't know
if I want a boss that's not the only
reason that's the surface level
apprehension with him he's actually
um Pedro Pascal and Bella Ramsay had a
couple of great emotional scenes in here
great monologue and emotional heavy
dialogue when Pedro Pascal's talking
with Tommy and he's like I I'm not the
one to to take her on this Mission you
know it shouldn't be me it should be you
but I get it the dude sees a girl there
it reminds him of his daughter he's like
I he can't bear the thought of losing a
daughter again on the other hand Ellie
can't stand the concept of being
abandoned by a father figure who is Joel
so it's like that that concept was
always in this show but this is the
episode that's like it's front and
center they're coming face to face with
these emotions they're coming face to
face with the concept of we can either
deny this reality entirely or we can
accept it and proceed accordingly but in
that scene where Joel is spilling his
heart and basically pleading to not keep
going with the mission couldn't help but
see that as his that's his Jesus in The
Garden of Gethsemane moment he's like if
we can go ahead and not do the thing
um let's go ahead and do that instead oh
I have the choice
oh
I'll do the thing [__] responsibility
paraphrasing maybe that was in the
original Bible but this was a great Joel
and Ellie episode they came face to face
with each other in the concept of each
other and after that they're laughing
joking you're like oh they've accepted
the father-daughter dynamic that is them
then yeah they're like oh the fireflies
aren't in this town they get attacked
dude stabs Joel with a bat I mean the
bat broke off so it's basically a wooden
Spike but yeah it gets stabbed and it
leaves off with Ellie like I don't know
what please don't leave me don't die
don't do this end of episode what a
great way to end
great way to end an episode this was
actually one of the rare times I don't
usually look at the hey next week on The
Last of Us I was like I have to I have
to see I gotta see the sneak peek next
week's episode is actually the flashback
episode with Ellie we get the DLC
episode which I can see why it's
important there this is going to be the
episode that sets up La in the next
episode's going to be Ellie's basically
big Coming of Age story as this episode
shows she's becoming more efficient
she's good at keeping watch at night but
this is a real sink or swim kind of
scenario she's in now but this episode
was what I've Loved about the show so
far which was Joel LA and their
emotional Dynamic this father-daughter
dynamic neither of them wants to
recognize now they've been forced to
come face to face with it right so the
Last of Us episode six have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]